Mandela un symbole contre l'apartheid de
documentaire réalisé par François-Xavier
des stores car nous venons de le voir
c'est lorsqu'il était emprisonné que
d'autres se sont chargés de forger la
figure emblématique de la lutte
anti-apartheides qu'il est devenu
Mandela reste aujourd'hui encore un
symbole planétaire de paix et de
réconciliation mais qu'a-t-il réellement
laissé en héritage en Afrique du Sud
là-bas n'a-t-on pas déjà trahi sa
promesse d'une nation arc-en-ciel nous
allons en parler maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc avec vous tout d'abord retirez
vircoulomb bienvenue vous êtes chercheur
associé au Centre Afrique subsaharienne
de l'IFRI l'IFRI bien sûr l'Institut
français des relations internationales
Nicolas normand est également avec nous
bienvenue et vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur de France au Mali au Sénégal
au Congo chercheur associé à l'IRIS
l'Institut de relations internationale
et stratégique et auteur de cet ouvrage
Le grand livre de l'Afrique un ouvrage
de se procurer chez eyrol vous étiez par
ailleurs chargé d'affaires au sein de
l'Ambassade de France en Afrique du Sud
après Toria durant la période 94 97 on y
reviendra avec vous dans un instant
Marie Roger billot est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes éditorialiste
dirigeante du groupe MRB production je
vais peut-être commencer avec vous parce
que ceux qui nous regardent doivent le
savoir vous avez été la première
française à ramener une interview de
Nelson Mandela elle a publié en France
c'était juste après sa libération est-ce
qu'à ce moment-là il pensait déjà à la
présidence de ce pays à la présidence de
l'Afrique du Sud il sera président
quatre ans plus tard est-ce qu'il y
pensait déjà et ce qu'il avait déjà un
véritable plan d'avenir pour son pays
des salaires alors ça c'est intéressant
de voir ça comme ça mais moi je pense
que je pense que beaucoup de pensent
aussi que c'était Alder naturel tout
combat qui s'est fait les les années
précédentes à Libération avait pour but
de le libérer en le désignait comme
notre leader ça faisait partie des
conditions voilà les ce qui se battait
le gauventé le père de tabo
des gens comme
tous ces anciens camarades on peut les
citer son nombreux mais et nous aussi
qui est dans des mouvements
anti-apartheides ils nous disait
réclamer une seule chose la libération
de Mandela c'est notre leader c'est avec
lui que nous voulons construire
l'Afrique du Sud d'après donc c'était
naturel que ce soit lui le président
d'une nouvelle Afrique du Sud et je me
souviens par contre
ce que serait cette prise de pouvoir
à l'époque l'interview que qu'on avait
fait à l'époque a un peu inquiété les
gens parce que il reprenait des thèses
de ses marxiste sur
le collectivisme
n'est-ce pas cette économie dirigée par
l'État etc
il était l'ANC a été allié très
longtemps avec le Parti communiste
sud-africain qui c'est une spécialité de
ce pays le Parti communiste africain
était plutôt blanc était représenté par
les blancs comme jocelot par exemple
alors vous l'avez rencontré un tout
petit peu plus tard lorsque vous étiez
en poste on l'a dit à Pretoria vous
l'avez rencontrer à plusieurs reprises
en tant que Chargé d'affaires au sein de
l'Ambassade de France en Afrique du Sud
là il avait déjà entamé son mandat
présidentiel il n'en fera qu'un à la
tête de ce pays
qu'est-ce qui avait changé entre le
Mandela de 90 c'est celui que vous avez
rencontré il était en charge et il était
face à
évidemment aux réforme auxquelles qu'il
devait mettre en place pour ce pays il
avait déjà fait un premier point avec
vous des difficultés à avancer pour ce
pays alors de mon point de vue bandela
n'a pas changé pendant les 27 ans de son
emprisonnement avant aussi et après sa
libération c'est-à-dire ça a toujours
été un homme qui recherchait la
réconciliation l'entente et qui n'était
pas du tout attiré par le communisme
c'est vrai que le Parti communiste
sud-africain avait rallié la NC le parti
de Mandela mais lui n'a jamais eu de
conviction inspirée du marxisme c'était
plutôt contraire quelqu'un qui assistait
sur les responsabilités individuelles
c'était quelqu'un qui était chrétien
également donc il n'était pas dans une
optique de collectivisme donc il n'a pas
changé je pense dans sa doctrine il
voulait avant tout une situation de
modération évitez un antagonisme et des
violences il voulait une réconciliation
entre le régime qui était oppressif à
l'époque qui était radical et lui qui
était modéré
la tête d'une population noire qui
aurait eu des raisons de se rebeller il
y avait un certain nombre de leaders
noirs qui voulaient des représailles qui
voulaient une violence et lui il
prêchait à la fois contre les
extrémistes noires et contre les
extrémistes blancs en fait il incarnait
une modération et une volonté de
réconcilier tous les habitants d'Afrique
de sud et cette réconciliation sera
symbolisée par une nouvelle constitue
sur dans ce pays ça se rajouter en 96
qui concrétisera cette société
multiraciale il était question de mettre
en place bien entendu à l'occasion de sa
première présidente alors quant à vous
vous l'avez rencontré mais après qu'il
ait fini cette présidence il a passé la
main à MBK vous l'avez cité tout à
l'heure il tirait déjà un premier bilan
de ce qui avait été sa présidence
justement des chantiers qu'il fallait
continuer à mener en Afrique en Afrique
du Sud vous l'avez rencontré la pandémie
à peu près la particularité de de
Nel demander là c'est que justement il a
fait qu'un seul mandat et il est parti
en
partant vraiment c'est à dire pas en
voulant jouer le rôle de président
derrière le président et de continuer en
quelque sorte à inspirer la politique ou
attirer les ficelles de la politique
sud-africaine lorsqu'il est parti il a
dit bon je pars je passe la main à tabo
mbki et je me retire en grande partie de
la vie politique il était il est vrai à
cette époque fatiguée et il avait des
responsabilités internationales puisque
il était médiateur il avait été appelé
pour être médiateur et notamment dans le
conflit burunday dans la guerre civile
burundaise à cette époque et donc il a
c'était une grande surprise pour
beaucoup d'acteurs politiques
sud-africains de le voir se retirer
véritablement et de donner toutes les
reines à tabo MBK sans vouloir jouer le
président derrière le président le
premier constat c'est que une démocratie
a été mise en place avec Mandela
et peut-être démocratie elle est
toujours en place nous sommes dans un
pays démocratique bon c'est pas le cas
de tous les pays en Afrique loin de là
vous le savez très bien
c'est une démocratie qui a duré c'est un
système démocratique qui 28 ans après
l'accession de Mandela à la présidence
continue de fonctionner est-ce qu'on
peut dire ça oui tout à fait c'est une
démocratie constitutionnelle où il y a
un grand attachement à la constitution
de 96 et aux différentes équilibres qu'à
l'instant et c'est aussi un pays qui a
de vrai contre-pouvoir avec un secteur
privé qui est assez puissant avec une
société civile qui est très très active
et aussi qui est assez influente donc à
l'inverse de beaucoup d'autres pays
africains on peut dire que il y a une
vraie un vrai enracinement de la
démocratie et que ce n'est pas quelque
chose de cosmétique ça c'est vraiment à
mettre au crédit de demande d'Ella avec
un pouvoir judiciaire en plus qui est
important puisque la Cour
constitutionnelle a quand même condamné
le président Zuma pour corruption donc
c'est un des rares pays africains même
dans le monde il y en a pas beaucoup une
cour constitutionnelle à un pouvoir de
condamner un chef d'État Jacob Zuma qui
aura exercé le pouvoir après un béquille
on y reviendra tout à l'heure et ça oui
je pense que l'une des l'un des
héritages de la période Mandela et de
tout le combat qui a précédé c'est cette
Constitution qui est qui était je me
souviens à l'époque on disait c'est la
meilleure constitution du monde
puisqu'elle était multiraciale etc elle
avait été
conçue par des gens comme albissax et là
je dois dire que la la communauté juive
à l'époque a été extrêmement active dans
la construction de cette période et elle
s'est beaucoup investie elle a aussi
payé le prix fort parce que je pense à
des gens comme Joe solo et en
particulier à son épouse rotfirst qui
est une de mes idoles qui les
journalistes et c'était des gens qui les
Juifs étaient blancs donc ils
souffraient pas spécialement de
l'Apartheid mais ne le supportez pas
pour les autres non plus au nom de leur
culture humaniste et des gens comme
route first ont été assassinés par les
services secrets sud-africains dans les
pays de la ligne du foot de France Joss
levo a passé aussi des vingtaine
d'années en prison aux côtés là et ils
étaient très nombreux sous un susman
enfin bon très nombreux et ça je crois
que on a cette héritage la Constitution
qui a qui a voilà soudé une société
noire et blanche multiraciale et je
crois que personne n'a envie vraiment de
de voilà de la violer d'une manière
c'est pas qu'ils ont pas envie mais
comme disait il y a les comptes pour
pouvoir sont forts pour les défendre
constitution pierre angulaire
constitutionnelle posée par Nelson
Mandela et cette première présidente
d'une société multéractielle en Afrique
du Sud c'est tabo mbki qui donc lui
succédera tabbéké entre 1999 et 2008
c'est presque demande à un tout à fait
mais presque de deux mandats bilan
mitigé pour cette présidente mbki à en
croire tout ce qu'on j'ai pu lire pour
préparer cette émission d'abord il opte
pour un système libéral du point de vue
économique qui va creuser ou accentuer
peut-être certaines inégalités et puis
une réaction face au sida et une
politique sanitaire qui sera remise très
visée en cause par par les Sud Africains
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous ce
bilan MBK à la tête du pays après
Mandela pas ce bilan comme vous l'avez
dit c'est c'est mal achevé enfin
Président c'est malachevé puisque il a
été démis à cause des luttes
satisfaction dans la NC et d'ailleurs
comme Jacob Zuma donc on voit bien qu'il
y a un problème politique assez profond
puisque ça fait maintenant deux
présidents qui n'arrivent pas à finir
leur deuxième mandat en Afrique du Sud
et celui qui est actuellement au pouvoir
aussi ses difficultés
et donc c'était selon un Cyril
un bilan très mitigé le début d'une
dérive de l'ANC dans la corruption
puisque les privatisations que vous
parliez de la politique économique qu'il
avait lancé néolibéral s'est faite
essentiellement en faveur d'une classe
d'une nomenclatural de la NC qui s'est
constituée à la faveur de ses
privatisations et donc dès ce moment-là
il a commencé à avoir un certain nombre
de scandales et d'affaires politiques
aux financière qui n'ont jamais cessé et
qui sont maintenant un flux ininterrompu
en Afrique du Sud depuis trois
présidents et dont le dernier dont nous
parlions maintenant ciré Rama posa est
également empêtré dans une série
d'affaires financière donc pour moi ta
boom Becky ça a été le début de la
corruption dans l'anc et le début de la
dérive de la NC en fait et de situation
maintenant de corruption systémique
c'est un pays inégalitaire il y a une
étude de la Banque mondiale qui est
assez récente qui date de mars dernier
et qui nous dit que d'une manière
générale l'Afrique australe et la partie
la plus inégalitaire au monde et
l'Afrique du Sud est le pays le plus
inégalitaire au monde selon la Banque
mondiale aujourd'hui
ça c'est un véritable échec pour tous
ceux qui ont succédé à Mandela non alors
c'est une façon de voir les choses je
suis d'accord évidemment avec Thierry
virkoulon il y a eu ce problème de
corruption un problème de mauvaise
gouvernance mais il faut aussi voir le
point de départ ou là les inégalités
étaient plus que flagrante puisque
90% des terres appartenaient à des
blancs au moment où Mandela a pris le
pouvoir
et la totalité des de l'industrie la
totalité des sociétés privées donc le
rôle la mission de Mandela et ensuite
des présidents qui ont suivi étaient
quand même de permettre à 90% de la
population puisque c'est 90 % la
population est noir à peu près de
devenir propriétaire des moyens de
production alors Mandela a voulu le
faire de façon pacifique transitoire il
a fait le contraire de ce qui s'est
passé au Zimbabwe avec Mugabe Mugabe
c'était des expropriations massives et
sans indemnités des terres tandis que là
il y a eu un objectif de racheter 30%
des terres pour les rendre à la
population noire
en indemnisant les propriétaires blancs
il s'agissait pas non plus de casser
l'agriculture et sa production
finalement assez peu de blanc ont quitté
le pays n'est ce pas à peu près 15% des
6 ou 7 millions de blancs sont partis
les autres sont restés
et il s'agissait aussi de transférer le
capital de l'industrie à la population
Douarre alors c'est vrai que c'est l'ANC
et une certaine classe noire en fait
l'élite noire ceux qui avaient pu être
éduqué malgré le système de la partage
donc c'est une minorité noire à peu près
10 % qui a pu profiter de ce transfert
de propriété des du capitalisme blanc
vers un certain capitaliste noir mais
l'objectif est de transférer un peu plus
de 40% du capital de l'industrie à la
population noire et d'avoir 40% des
cadres qui soient noirs donc 40% avec
l'émergence d'une classe moyenne donc
noire donc il s'agit pas de chasser les
blancs il s'agit de faire un partage
plus équitable néanmoins ça c'est une
version assez optimiste c'est une vision
un peu optimiste pour pouvoir d'où on
partait en réalité pour voir où on en
est aujourd'hui néanmoins les inégalités
persistent puisque jamais on dit
aujourd'hui que l'Afrique du Sud sur un
plan social serait sur une marmite
qui n'attend que que de sauter cette
marmite et bien
tout est possible certes mais
effectivement c'est très important de
constater que ce pays ne sait pas
effondré
je me souviens à l'époque en disait bon
d'abord les les blancs menacé de partir
voilà on va pas être black whool sur le
gouvernement du noir on va tous partir
c'est pas possible bon finalement c'est
juste une infime minorité qui est partie
et
je dirais la direction noire a quand
même tenue le pays tant bien que mal et
c'est très important toujours de voir
d'où il vient mais cela dit
nous qui étions dans un combat idéaliste
voilà les la le l'égalité entre les
races l'harmonie etc des concepts très
philosophiques c'est le combat idéaliste
de Mandela complètement c'était de cette
génération là donc c'est successeurs ont
trahi
on est quand même on a été un peu déçu
de voir que c'était devenu
uniquement voilà très axé sur la
consommation pour réussir c'était de
s'asseoir pouvoir s'asseoir dans les les
mots les dépenser voilà c'était avec
quelque chose d'assez terre à terre et
de décevant et après justement comme ce
substratifs morales solide c'est un peu
dilué on a vu l'Afrique du Sud voilà ça
donnait à une xénophobie mais totalement
débridée
qui était partiellement encouragé aussi
par des dirigeants il y avait les
espèces de Peaugres contre les Africains
qui venaient de certains pays et jusqu'à
maintenant on a on a une ambiance très
négative vis-à-vis des voilà des des
pays des gens des pays originaires
depuis voisins qui viennent travailler
tout ça c'est
c'est encouragé c'est compris et c'est
très décevant parce qu'on sait que
beaucoup de ces pays ont participé à la
lutte contre l'apartheid et ont payé
aussi
souvent président parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de mozambicans qui sont là-bas
entre autres vous savez donc
ça c'est un des points noirs de la
primaire on a parlé des inégalités vous
avez parlé de la corruption on va y
revenir tout de même un moment parce
qu'on a le sentiment que cette
corruption à
gagner ce pays après Mandela sans jamais
vraiment le quitter avec cette fameuse
présidente Jacob Zuma il y a eu
effectivement une une enquête judiciaire
qui a duré très longtemps quatre ans et
qui prouve par A + B qui effectivement
lui le premier
a été corrompu et que il a été victime
d'affairiste
indien en l'occurrence cette corruption
continue du tel à gangrener le pays ou
alors est-ce que Cyril ramafosa a réussi
à arrêter de corruption c'était sa
promesse pour accéder à sa présidence
oui tout à fait en fait il est il est
arrivé au pouvoir justement pour
nettoyer les écuries d'ogias de Jacob
Zuma et donc nettoyer le parti et
lui-même actuellement se trouve pris
dans un scandale qu'on appelle là-bas le
farm gate ou des cambrioleurs ont volé
dans sa dans sa ferme plusieurs millions
de dollars en cache donc tout le monde
en Afrique du Sud se demande pourquoi le
président avait plusieurs millions de
dollars en cage dans sa résidence
secondaire et il y a actuellement une
discussion au Parlement pour savoir si
on va lui poser la question
officiellement c'est à dire c'est une
commission d'enquête va le convoquer
pour lui poser cette question est-ce que
ça pose pas la question de la NC de la
place de la NC aujourd'hui sur
l'échiquier politique sud-africain la NC
domine depuis évidemment
1994 et cette accession de Mandela à la
présidence d'Afrique du Sud elle gagne
toutes les élections mais on sent que
c'est de plus en plus difficile que la
NC est de plus en plus contestée il y a
une équation peut dire de cette
évolution de l'ANC certaine maintenant
et là je crois 57% de la population qui
vote en faveur de la NC alors qu'au
départ c'était plus de 90 % pratiquement
beaucoup de Blancs étaient procès aussi
il faut le dire tout le monde n'était
pas partisan dans la communauté blanche
du système de la partail mais je crois
que tous ces difficultés qui ont été
rencontrées la corruption la mauvaise
gouvernance l'accroissement des
inégalités la pauvreté qui se maintient
la dégradation sociale
malgré une certaine croissance
économique de plus 5% par an en moyenne
criminalité aussi
ce sont des héritages de la partage de
mon point de vue c'est des héritages de
la situation antérieure où la population
noire c'est-à-dire 90% du Mont des gens
étaient complètement exclus du système
n'est-ce pas ils étaient relayés dans
des bancs tout ce temps ou alors dans
des espèces de bidonvilles où il n'avait
aucun droit
aucun revenu ils étaient presque
esclavagés on peut le dire ils étaient
dans un système incroyable et donc on
peut pas transformer une société aussi
incroyablement inégalitaire en une
société normale sans violence pacifique
sans corruption sans problème comme ça
en quelques dizaines d'années c'est une
affaire immense je crois que Nelson
Mandela a donné la bonne direction
c'est-à-dire qu'il a voulu éviter les
mesures autoritaires les mesures
brutales toutes celles qui ont échoué au
Zimbabwe il a voulu le faire dans une
transition douce sans effrayer personne
en essayant de voilà alors mais c'est un
exercice extrêmement difficile donc
c'est normal qu'on se heurte à plein de
problèmes vous souhaitez rajouter
quelque chose le oui il y a une
peut-être de l'héritage de l'apartheid
le oui enfin en Afrique du Sud si vous
voulez l'apartheid c'était il y a 30 ans
donc il y a déjà toute une génération
qui n'a pas connu l'apartheid et qui
s'appelle les bornes free enfin ce qu'on
appelle là-bas les bornes Free et qui
eux disent que
l'ANC est en haut au pouvoir depuis
qu'ils sont nés c'est l'ANC qui est
redevable de la situation de gouvernance
du pays puisque c'est elle qui au
pouvoir s'en partage depuis 1994 puisque
elle a une majorité extrêmement forte au
Parlement mais qui ne cesse de diminuer
qui était à son maximum en 99 avec 70%
qui est descendu aux élections aux
dernières élections à 57% et tous les
instituts de sondage disent qu'ils vont
passer la barre des 50% aux prochaines
élections et donc ils sont dans une
situation extrêmement délicate parce que
justement quand on analyse les élections
on voit que les nouvelles générations de
d'électeurs qui arrivent et bien sont
extrêmement électeurs noirs sont
extrêmement critiques à l'égard de la NC
sont très souvent des abstentionnistes
aussi l'abstention et la grande gagnante
des derniers scrutins électoraux et
également sont de plus en plus tentés un
parti qui s'appelle les économies
freudame Fighter ce qui représente une
certaine catégorie de la jeunesse
sud-africaine qui est un parti beaucoup
plus radical assez populiste assez
démagogique etc donc un vrai procès qui
a été fait par la NC qui est fait par la
NC par la jeunesse mais qui a également
été fait par les vétérans de la lutte et
les gens qui est avaient l'âge de Nelson
Mandela mais qui était encore vivant
lors du scandale de la présidence de
Jacob Zuma puisque ce sont eux qui se
sont mobilisés dans le parti les anciens
si je puis dire pour se débarrasser de
lui et pour dire que la corruption avait
atteint maintenant un degré qui était
absolument inadmissible dans l'anc
est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il existe bel
et bien ça a un peu été évoqué une
alternative politique à l'ANC
aujourd'hui en Afrique du Sud où est-ce
qu'on n'est pas encore on en est pas
encore tout à fait là absolument c'est
je crois que tout ça est en marche et la
NC a été très longtemps un parti
submersible un peu comme le FLN en
Algérie tout est parti qui ont qui sont
issus des luttes etc qui ont une énorme
légitimité mais au fil se parlerisme
parce que on voit donc comment sauf que
il y a un contexte plus démocratique que
l'autre il y a l'Afrique du Sud et on
voit comment émerge de nouvelles forces
comme ce il y a aussi un parti blanc qui
avec Hélène ville qui qui a une certaine
audience et
vient de nous citer un parti
des revendications plus radicales mais
alors plus radicales dans quel sens qui
remettra en cause cet équilibre
multiracial auquel tout de même se
payait parvenu alors c'est pas
l'équilibre multination mais juste on
aimerait avoir davantage de cette
prospérité économique enfin tu es
économique freedom fight c'était bien
les armes et tout ça les biologistes
c'est bien mais maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on met dans les assiettes pourquoi
n'a pas autant que les blancs en gros et
avec voilà mais ce qui est intéressant
avec ce parti que c'est il a une
certaine forme de popularité au-delà des
frontières parce que il a un discours
plus panafricaniste que les autres parce
que ce qui frappe justement après le
combat qui a été international contre
l'apartène on voit comment
l'ancienne un petit peu replié sur ces
questions là à soutenir des des voilà
des des politiques qui excluent un peu
les étrangers devenant des pays voisins
mais lui aussi et donc et aussi autre
phénomène il est en train de reprendre
son compte le sentiment anti français
qui qu'on voit beaucoup en Afrique de
l'Ouest dans les pays francophones il a
fait une manifestation absolument
impressionnante devant l'ambassade de
France
en Afrique du Sud pour
demander la fin du français
vraiment etc donc
il a des connexions avec d'autres jeunes
à travers le continent sur ces questions
là vous le voyez comment cet avenir
politique de l'Afrique du Sud
effectivement c'est un pays qui est un
peu à la croisée des chemins il faut
espérer de mon point de vue que les
radicaux ne l'emporteront pas et que les
populistes qui ont en réalité de fausses
solutions
l'emporte parce que je crois que
demander là il faut garder au contraire
son héritage c'est-à-dire l'idée de
faire une transition sans violence
consensuelle en quelque sorte parce
qu'on ne peut pas déposséder trop
rapidement
les propriétaires terriens ni les
propriétaires des industries il faut un
black campowerman c'est-à-dire une
arrivée au pouvoir économique de la
majorité noire de façon progressive donc
c'est pas encore le cas non c'est pas
c'est en cours c'est en cours mais pour
l'instant effectivement la majorité des
terres continuent d'appartenir aux
blancs et la majorité du capital
industriel continue d'appartenir au
blanc mais c'est là aussi où sont les
traditions de compétences ce sont les ce
sont ceux qui ont créé ces industries le
transfert est nécessaire parce qu'il
faut que le pouvoir économique reflète
le pouvoir démographique le pouvoir
politique c'est absolument nécessaire
pour la stabilité mais ça ne peut pas se
faire du jour au lendemain il n'y a pas
de baguette magique les pays qui ont
voulu le faire brutalement l'exemple et
pas loin c'est le Zimbabwe ça a été une
catastrophe donc il faut éviter la
catastrophe économique de simbabwe
Mandela l'avait très bien compris moi je
souhaite qu'on reste sur la la ligne
voulue par Mandela parce que je n'envoie
pas d'autres possibles pour ce pays
alors ce transfert de je dirais de
pouvoir économique à la majorité noire
en particulier le partage des terres est
un sujet tabou en Afrique du Sud ils
veulent rien faire je crois que le cas
de la du Zimbabwe a été épouvantail mais
on voit pas ce qui est en train de se
faire même si ça doit être progressif je
crois que c'est carrément bloqué
c'est un sujet tabou et ben parce que on
se dit que ça va créer des désordres
énormes on a vu le Zimbabwe justement le
fait de de
s'approprier des terrains appartenant
des terres appartenant au blanc qui
avait tout justement de Mane qui
eux-mêmes c'était avait arraché les
terrains des Africains à conduit à une
crise économique dans le pays séparé
donc en Afrique du Sud on est vite
soigneusement ce sujet sauf justement ce
parti de économique freedom fight alors
je pense pas qu'on évite ce sujet parce
que il y a un objectif officiel pour
2025 d'avoir atteint 30% de 30% des
terres qui appartiendront à des fermiers
noirs en faisant mais il y a deux
difficultés c'est qu'il faut financer le
rachat des terres au fermier blanc
première difficulté budgétaire deuxième
difficulté il faut trouver des candidats
agriculteurs qui ont la compétence
technique il faut pas que l'agriculture
s'effondre comme elle s'est effondrée au
Zimbabwe donc ce sont il y a peut-être
des problèmes politiques mais
essentiellement je pense que ce sont des
problèmes politiques des problèmes
budgétaires et des problèmes techniques
l'Afrique du Sud a eu une influence ce
qui s'est passé en Afrique du Sud a eu
une influence sur l'ensemble du
continent africain est-ce que cela
continue l'Afrique du Sud a été
médiateur dans un certain nombre de
conflits par exemple après la présidence
Mandela est-ce que l'influence de
l'Afrique du Sud est quelque chose de
très tangible sur le continent africain
aujourd'hui et en quoi non l'Afrique du
Sud c'est un pays qui a perdu énormément
en affluence et son son image
internationale qui était très positive
il y a 20 ans et maintenant très
négative
elle s'est elle a elle a opté elle a
fait des choix qui n'ont pas été très
heureux si je puis dire Jacob Zuma avait
opté en effet pour proximité avec la
Russie
ils ont même une politique qui n'est pas
très lisible une politique étrangère qui
n'est pas très lisible et surtout leur
tentative pour être important à l'Union
africaine à échoué puisque lorsqu'ils
ont eu la la tête lorsqu'il est dirigé
l'Union africaine ça a laissé un très
très mauvais souvenir
aux autres pays membres et Madame la
misizouma qui a été à Nice Abeba à ce
moment-là a été une animal détestée on
peut le dire donc et en plus leur
politique étrangère voilà n'avait pas
beaucoup de lisibilité essayer de
naviguer entre la Chine la Russie et
d'autres intérêts et
a montré que elle était en fait peu à
l'examen diplomatique qui était peu
performant et une armée qui était
complètement déclin ce qui n'aura pas
permis de jouer un rôle important dans
les opérations de maintien de la paix en
Afrique ou au contraire ils ont ils ont
sont embourbés notamment dans une
opération en Centrafrique où ils ont
perdu des hommes alors que la population
sud-africaine ne savait pas qu'ils
avaient envoyé leur armée dans ce pays
donc ça a créé quand même beaucoup de
troubles et maintenant ce n'est plus
considéré comme un part important ça
c'était considéré il y a 20 ans comme un
partenaire essentiel sur le continent et
actuellement c'est vraiment un pays de
ce point de vue là on déclin alors il
nous reste deux minutes pardonnez-moi
mais marie-rocher
il y a deux échanges importantes la
présidente de la NC va être mise en jeu
ça sera à la fin de cette année d'une
part puis il y a des élections générales
qui sont prévues en 2024 est-ce que si
Cyril Rama fossa a une chance d'être élu
à la présidence de la NC selon vous et
donc assez logiquement de se représenter
aux élections générales et en 2024 ou
est-ce que le personnel politique à la
tête de l'ANC risque de changer compte
tenu tout ce qu'on s'est dit juste avant
tout est possible vous savez c'est des
forces en mouvement mais le l'ANC
représente un corps quand même plus de
50% dans les intentions de vote donc il
reste un poids même s'il a diminué et
pour ça je voulais aussi quand même
saluer quelque chose qui est positif
qu'on voit aujourd'hui dans l'Afrique du
Sud contemporaine c'est cette
coopération sur le plan culturel entre
les blancs et les Noirs donc les les
Sud-Africains sont un peu leaders en
termes de design de architecture etc
parce que cette collaboration et il faut
quand même le signaler pour pas qu'on
voit un petit peu cette héritage les
gens ne sont pas totalement séparés il y
a beaucoup de points de divergence et
des collaboration avec seulement
fructueuses je voulais votre point de
vue vous sur sur la suite à la tête de
l'ANC et ce qui pourrait se profiler à
l'horizon des prochaines élections
générales en fait c'est un système à
deux élections parce qu'il y a une sorte
de primaire à l'intérieur de l'ANC et
ensuite les élections les primaires vont
être très durs parce que la lutte de
faction est intense à l'intérieur de la
NC et comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le président Rama posa est empêtré dans
des affaires difficiles lui aussi lui
aussi
comme les autres et donc les primaires
vont être très difficiles il est pas
évident qu'il passe et après lors des
prochaines élections moi j'entends des
sondages un peu différents avec 42%
d'attention de vote mais en tout cas la
plupart des sondeurs estiment qu'ils
passeront la barre des en dessous des
50%. ce qui est déjà un événement
historique depuis la présidente
aussi bas et ça les forcera à s'allier
avec les économies freedom Fighter s'ils
veulent avoir une majorité dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure ça sera le mot de
la fin vraiment un grand grand merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat doc consacré aujourd'hui et bien à
la prenne Nelson Mandela après ce
documentaire qui nous a rappelé un œuvre
de Mandela vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag débat docs bien sûr sur Twitter
merci aussi à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à préparer cette
émission puis je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]